today I'm going to share what i did for
Valentine's Day
[Music]
so originally Valentine's Day and in
general i struggle with Valentine's Day
because I'm the one hand i'm not a big
fan of just buying into made-up holidays
and I like doing things just because I
would much rather do something just
because I feel like it has more meaning
than when you're forced to do something
I maybe just in general I don't like
being forced to do anything maybe that
like is at the core of everything this
message of murder don't put Evan in a
box I want to do my own thing yeah maybe
that's probably at the corbett but on
the other hand i really like the idea of
celebrating love and so every year I try
to figure out something special to do
and so in past years I've done cooking
the meal for Nina getting everything set
up for her and surprising her at home by
that I've also surprised her work and
you know showed up in a tie that had
hearts on it and balloons and flowers
and I've given her presence i guess like
we all do a different times would give
different presents and i don't know this
year I felt like I wanted to do
something a little more meaningful I
wanted to something that had you know
what I wanted to tell that had more
lasting impact I feel like if she just
world to dinner at a restaurant it's
kind of a lazy way out it's kind of the
expected thing to do and maybe yeah it's
a great evening but it fades and I
wanted to do something that had much
more impact that lasted a longer time as
well as struggling what do i do what do
I do that has that deep meaningful
impact in my solution actually cost zero
dollars it costs a ton of time but
didn't cost me any money what I ended up
doing was writing her a letter as to the
reasons why I love her and I thought
back to when we first started our
relationship or just dating and kind of
worked our way through open to the
present day all the different things
that I love about her and why and I just
wanted her to feel it as I was writing
it I started getting the motion I'd like
take some breaks
then come back to it and she opened it
at work and she read the first paragraph
he's different emotional which is the
goal right like deep meaningful impact
was the purpose that I wanted to have
and so she was reading it and had to put
it away and come back to it later so
she's not crying at her at her desk with
told workers kind of looking at what's
going on anja it took me as I said a
number of hours to put this thing
together and in all honestly took me
more time to do that than to both go
restaurant or to prepare a meal or to
clean up or to show up with flowers you
know any of the other stuff that I would
have done it didn't cost me anything in
terms of dollars would cost me a lot in
terms of time and ended up having you
know the results that I wanted and I
don't know what I'm gonna do next year
we'll see we'll see how I'm feeling and
go with that vibe there but I wanted to
share it with you guys because I think a
lot of times one we do things maybe for
the wrong reasons we do things because
we're forced to do something or we do
think there are at a very superficial
level and then too we feel like we have
to do something just for somebody else's
expectations we need to go out and we
need to buy that thing and that's that's
the thing that's going to make that
person happy right I need to go out and
buy them this expensive present for them
to be happy and you may not be able to
afford that thing and really the results
the wind you get from that present that
super expensive gift doesn't lie you
know doesn't have a long-term impact and
so what really touches people's hearts
is that deep expression of gratitude and
especially somebody you know but you're
in a relationship with why you love them
I'd encourage you to try that out
yourself and you know what is a good
challenge leave nation whether you're
married or not I want you to find
somebody in your life today who you just
want to express some thanks to and you
can pick up the phone and give them a
call or write them a nice letter or send
them an email just something really
touching as to why they've impacted your
life and how
I want you to feel the emotion I want
you to get choked up in writing that
email or making that phone call to
express how deeply this person has
impacted you and again it could be a
friend it could be a parent it could be
a sibling the cookie doesn't have to be
your spouse if you're not married I want
you to get choked up and running that
message and if you do that they're
probably going to get choked up to
they're probably going to really
appreciate you for writing that message
and even if they don't worst case
scenario it's still a gift you writing
that the intention is positive it's
still a gift and so I'd love to
challenge you today as we close the
weekend to send somebody a nice message
of how this impacted you and I guarantee
you're going to feel good about it and
hopefully so will they that's it hope
you guys have a great weekend I believe
in you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is let's love
sees